having just led a mission by a team of
inspectors to the zaparizian nuclear
power plant a place that's been shelled
repeatedly the head of the iaea spoke to
the security Council about his findings
the current situation he said was
dangerous and untenable the physical
attack wittingly or unwittingly
the hits that this facility has received
and that I could personally see and
assess together with my experts is
simply
unacceptable we are playing with fire
and something very very catastrophic
could take place he's now proposing a
demilitarized protection Zone around
zapparicha the largest nuclear power
plant in Europe it's a proposal that's
also strongly backed by the UN Secretary
General an agreement on a demilitarized
perimeter should be secured
specifically that would include the
commitment by Russian forces to withdraw
our military personnel and equipment
from that perimeter and the commitment
by Ukrainian forces not to move into it
both the Ukrainian and the Russian
ambassadors spoke in the meeting each
blaming the other for the shelling of
the plant after the security council
meeting I asked Russia's Ambassador
about the proposal for the demilitarized
zone I want to know the details same is
here I don't know do not know what
director General grocery means by that
to what extent it will improve the
safety
both physical
nuclear safety of the plant the proposal
for the demilitarized zone was supported
by most members of the security Council
but Russia and Ukraine both said they
wanted more details it's clear much more
diplomacy and persuasion will be needed
if this idea is ever to be turned into
reality James Bay's Al Jazeera at the
United Nations